we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p we had a
fascinating patriot mail this week
including the coining of the word zen
zen thought of obiga zento fo Beca right
zento fo Beca some kind of perverted
form of xenophobia and it also
referenced race wars in prison now I
will remind you the Eggman regular
caller to the show is both a Jewish man
and that's relevant to this voicemail
and a man who has spent time in a
federal penitentiary and he had the
following to say about that Hadrian male
I did I liked your hatred mail but I
didn't understand it this week I don't
understand why this guy thinks that if
Ritchie was in prison the blacks and the
Mexicans will hate him and few nasty
things to him the truth is the blacks
especially really respect use in perfect
the only what once you tell them you're
are the chosen people that's it they ask
you for stuff that unless they're the
Nation of Islam and are some of them in
prison and yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
about the Jews however if they still
respect them Jews do not get with in
prison
federal prison ok they run the majority
this guy's out of his mind but um it was
kind of funny otherwise love you pack
then like your crew good jobs follow
yeah alright always great to hear from
the eggman they're so clearly the hatred
it's shocking to me that hazier email
was not completely accurate yeah I mean
I've learned even in my short time here
not to try to rationalize the logic of
what the hate rates have to say we're
gonna lose a lot of sleep over it but
what is true is that when you try to
have an explanation for hatred mail you
end up with stuff that's really funny
like what the Eggman called in with so
that that we do know on the bonus show
today
headlines about a donald trump staffer
found guilty on ten counts of election
fraud are the headlines really
reflective of the core truth of the
story also sex with animals is one step
closer to becoming illegal in ohio so
that's your thing you should be aware of
what the law may be in ohio sooner than
later and new york times subscription
growth soars tenfold after the election
of
president Donald Trump as
president-elect of the United States we
will talk about that and also talk about
the just incredible November that the
David Pakman show had really on all
platforms but particularly with paid
subscribers reminder if you want to be a
david pakman show member but the normal
prices are too high use the coupon code
I voted 17 all one word all lowercase at
david pakman.com slash membership for a
nice discount because having you
involved at any level is my priority
talk to you on the bonus show